mark what is your job as a sound mixer
on the hateful eight and what does it
entail and the production sound mixer so
the equivalent in the music world would
be the creative recording producer I
come each day I deal in close quarters
with all the performers the cast to
capture their original performance and
with the Quentin it's a very specialized
circumstance because I've been with him
for over 22 years we've done everything
from dusk till dawn forward we met on
desperado actually when he came in
cameoed and Quinn's the only director
I've ever worked with where we've never
replaced a single word in
post-production on any film we've done
together it's it's a unique it's a
unique situation and it has to do with
ket with what we do but also in
conjunction with his commitment to
capturing the performance he sees that
day and that's going to be in a movie
period so that's what I do I captured
those original performances interesting
and what is the reason that he doesn't
want to change a word what he wants that
authenticity of that first be can you
tell me a little more about why it's
specifically done like that he he
believes it's part of his process he
believes pretty much old school - he
believes in the work that happens on the
day for example there's no video village
on a Quentin show there's no video
assist Quentin's in the room he's
sitting at the camera with the actors
side-by-side right there just like we're
sitting here right now and it's a it
builds a environment of support and
Trust for the cast and it's it's
hands-on for him as the director he's
not sort of to stepping and he's not
watching his movie on TV live every day
and that principle is applied to
everything else he looks for reality as
an environment to support the character
development to support the story arc
everything's about that what I do is as
I'm a musician in his orchestra
I saw a sideman session player and like
everyone else Bob Richardson the
cameraman or or Fred theater we we are
intensely committed to our instrument
but our instrument comes into full play
when we play in the orchestra together
and so Quentin is a real throwback to
old-school Hollywood
filmmaking his films may not be that for
people as they experience it but the
process is it's a he's a perpetual
student and we all are we're we're film
we're film crazies and and he's the lead
film crazy and that you know every we
you never say scene 25 7 you know Apple
Baker it's it's all God's or you know
there's always a game there's always
played its music on the set there is
this environment of creativity and he's
comfortable in his own skin and we all
are as well he wants you to bring your
game it's it's there's not a there's not
an ego wall there's no fear it's just
let's do it
you know downbeat on one no rehearsal
let's go that's an interesting statement
so if he's comfortable in his own skin
then that's that sort of the tone you
know how they say stuff rolls downhill
so if he yes if he's comfortable then it
sounds like everyone else feels it's
okay to be that way as well just idea
the day gets $5 oh nice I like that okay
it's like it's bring it you know but
it's in context you know you you there's
joy in that and there's serious it's a
serious thing to you know we're here
we're here to do this right is the piece
you know it's not we and we should have
a good time that but fun does not mean
disconnect fun means the thing the work
is the fun the fun you know so how much
notice does he have to give you well you
change your schedule and drop everything
or or he gives you a little more than
that um he's been incredibly generous in
that I usually have a six to eight month
lead on something coming down the road
you know this is gonna happen here want
to know can you clear your schedule and
and I do you know as we all do because
it's a unique place you know now I know
Quentin admits that his dialogue is not
always for everyone and that it doesn't
matter on you yes are one of our interns
ieave us found it and that it doesn't
matter sort of the quality of the actor
but it has to be the timing not every
actor can deliver the lines with the
timing and the humor that he wants so do
you see any diff
in some of the preparation with some of
the actors for his style of delivering
lines and filmmaking I think what I've
seen and this this has grown from the
early days to particularly last four or
five films I would say inglorious maybe
Kill Bill really but in Kill Bill and
glorious to me were sort of transitional
films to a different kind of filmmaking
for Quentin from my experience of
dealing with I mean I deal with a lot of
different directors but his his
evolution through my eyes was to let
those characters emerge in
pre-production through a prop you know
rehearsal they all do a read-through
they'll be you know weeks of you know
for example on this film
they built a proxy set in Los Angeles
for three four or five four weeks of
rehearsals so the actress could actually
be in the environment for their
rehearsal wasn't the set we were gonna
film it was you know cuz that was at ten
thousand feet until you're about
Telluride but it was a place for the
actors to find their characters in the
environment in which they're going to
operate because in many ways it's
analogous to a stage play they're all in
the same physical space River for almost
two-thirds of the movie and in
widescreen in this this ultra Panavision
format
it's a dramatically different approach
visually because unlike narrower frames
you're almost in a master type frame all
the time it the frame can include the
close-up the medium shot and the wide
shot all at once because there's so much
geography available and how you do that
how you do that aesthetically so the
whole sense of putting on a play like
performance comes out of that rehearsal
where the characters are at least
centered by before the actors with
Quentin in preparation that said the
true characters really don't emerge
until we actually start rolling film so
but the templates are their templates
they're like Jennifer Jennifer's
character was a revelation
but as revelation that happened when we
got there you know she brought a certain
kind of crazy that was and you know
completely original and I I don't know
if that was your experience but you know
and it really took the other actress now
they had someone to play against because
you needed that needed that back
pressure from her character for the
other characters to work and he knows
that he's great instincts about that I
love what he does with casting and
particularly how the ensemble there's no
there were no egos on this okay and
there never are he doesn't allow it
interesting so even though it is like a
band let's say there's no frontman
that's sort of the you have a conductor
okay you know and you have a score I
call the script you have a conductor
called called the director so there it's
not a democracy there's a leadership
process but it's it's a collaboration
you know I want your best you know
artists to come together you know every
shots hand handmade so you know it
doesn't happen in a box it doesn't come
preset it's a hundred people working to
get that that two minute thing to happen
so it fits into mosaic so when we're
sitting alone in a dark room or with a
group watching the movie we experienced
these as real characters on a real
journey and in this space and time that
but it's an illusion but that illusion
doesn't work unless you build that on
the inside you know build that from the
characters sound challenges in Telluride
versus the soundstage in Los Angeles
what were the two differences great
question
very different situations very different
telluride was all real environment you
know first we are went there for snow
but had no snow for a really long time
and and so we had to compensate in terms
of what we would shoot when we'd go
inside more than we had planned to
originally so those kinds of things or
create snow and there's 30 different
ways of creating snow mechanically you
know and each one has its issues and
from our side they're they're audible so
how you deal with that is in
pre-production a lot of conversations
different kinds of fan configurations
the to the diameters of tubes that blow
have to be wider the pumps that that
blow them have to be further away so all
of the you know minutiae of that prep
has to happen so that when you're there
and on the day your focus is on this not
that so that your focus is on the
performance and capturing us so so in
Telluride you're above 10,000 feet so
oxygen everybody's you know weeks
for the adapt to the altitude you are in
sub-zero when you get to work each
morning it's between minus 10 and minus
20 before the Sun hit the sky and at the
warmest part of the day might be 10 or
15 degrees Fahrenheit you're going to
locations that are not normally
accessible on foot so you're if you
would drive to them you'd ruin the snow
that has to be in the shot so you'd go
to a drop-off point and be on a
snowmobile to another point and then
you'd hike up a Ridge maybe a quarter of
a mile with your gear on impact on your
back and and you'd get up there and
settle in and everyone times times 100
because you're doing that but so is
everyone else
crane parts and just you know or they're
in there the night before so the
logistics are like intense very intense
and they're intense in an environment
that's very challenging to your body so
everyone had to sort of that's the
telluride part of this and the that
sounds difficult but it actually created
a kind of energy not just for us but for
the actors that they were really had
this resistance of the environment that
said the gear the things you use the
tools the hammers and nails
they're not used to that kind of
universe so you have to have a lot of
redundancy because things will fail and
you have to be very aware of the impact
if you work something in the cold a
piece of electronic gear and then you
bring it to a warm place there's going
to be condensation inside so it's like a
little rainstorm and your electronics
that are designed to make it and stop
working at the worst possible moment so
you don't do that you have a set of cold
things you have said of warm things the
cameras were built in 1979 for far and
away and the lenses were from 1955 you
know from Ben Hur and Khartoum so they
had to reconstruct the cameras down to
the ground and then rebuild them
viscosity of lubricants had to be
adaptable to the cold so they had to be
less viscosity because it would become
more the the the lubricants would go
slower in that colder weather so you had
to I mean it's just hundreds of those
little details they built custom 2,000
foot magazines for 70 millimeter because
no one shot two thousand foot magazines
before so coin could do these longer
play like takes you know and so the
cameras had to do that but they had to
be quiet enough
so that they wouldn't create a problem
for the dialogue so there's a
conversation with Panavision and and
Gregor tavern a who's Bob Richardson's
long-term you know camera assistant and
just all those details have to be
engaging so that's that's the rough
environment out there the stage it's
refrigerated it's 20 to 25 degrees and
they're pumping in humidity 95% humidity
to get the breath that's why we're
refrigerating the stage even though
we're inside you have to know that it's
always cold inside and if you notice all
that breathing none of that CGI no that
happened in a computer that's in the
room that's everyone is you know even in
the stage very cold and in the stage
there's no real snow to be had so
there's a greater application of
mechanical effects for snow and it's in
an enclosed space so the vulnerability
of the dialogue to that is much greater
so it's a constant collaboration with
the effects people the machines have to
go further away you have to turn it down
a little bit this is a very quiet piece
of dialogue but it's just what we did on
the set up before but it's not the same
because we're in a different physical
space the microphones are in a different
place we have to adapt even though it
seems the same that kind of
give-and-take everyday every shot every
minute and to stay on it stay in the
game you can never sort of back off from
that and and it's it's never created
tension because everybody knows that
what you're doing is to try and dial it
in so that when the camera rolls well
that's disappeared and it's just the
space where the performance can happen
that's that's sort of you know our core
collective mission the the wind sound
throughout the film which was great
because I felt physically cold the
entire time I was watching it I did too
but not because of the sound it was all
my muscle memory honestly was right
right from being there and tell you
writer or the trip I just cold as an
everyday thing is it's a different
perspective you know you know why they
drink so much in Scandinavia a fresh
source or to keep warm and there's not
really much you can do of course when
the weather's like that but with the
wind sound I'm assuming a lot of that
was all after-effects that you're not
actually combination some of it is about
helping
ask some of the mechanical stuff but but
really and this was from the outset
while e-statement who's been with
Quinton since since Kill Bill
brilliant brilliant artist and Mike
Miller's the other trio of the three of
us that have been with Quinton for a
long time in the sound side of things we
get together before a movie we sat and
combed through the script page by page
line by line you know weeks in advance
of even the the Scout pre-production to
look at brainstorm talk about approach
to this and wind from the very outset
was and this came from Quentin as well
it's a sort of a subliminal character in
the film this this blizzard that's there
it's part of what's driving the
stagecoach forward and it's what's what
you always have a sense of the the death
desolate you know isolation inside minis
because it's always there outside so the
wind is kind of I don't know if you
notice this the music in this film
compared to Quentin's other films is
relatively sparse yes but it really
isn't because the wind is that music and
the wind is is being used in so many
ways and Wiley was so skillful this in
terms of punctuation supporting a moment
having a silence that's underlined as a
silence because the wind is is there on
its own it was a very very design
oriented piece and we got material
that's real wind in the real place on
the real days but it's all it's all a
con it's all a creative construction
around the story arc around the
character arc you know so if there's
something that this is true about almost
all the elements in coin this film
whether it's a prop whether it's it's a
piece of dialogue whether it's a it's
it's you know the timing of something
the music's all real the piano playing
happens there on the set in the day with
the dialogue he doesn't break it away
Jennifer's guitar is a real thing she
prepped for months with that and did you
know about the guitar by the way no is
there a story behind oh yeah there's a
story the guitar is a rare was a rare
museum piece from the Martin guitar
museum that was on loan to the
production and they had made
about a half a dozen Chinese duplicates
of it for the breaking piece right right
so we're on the day doing this and she's
playing the real guitar cuz the tone and
the sound of that guitar is very unique
it's a it's a you know one hundred and
forty year old guitar you know worth
tens of thousands of dollars and for
some reason for some reason no one no
one and Kurt felt so bad about something
no one told Kurt about that so we're in
take we're in that take take one
encourage adders the real guitar no and
I don't know if you see Jennifer's face
when she goes if you see the film again
watch her face at the guitar shatter
that's because she's seeing a rare and
irreplaceable museum piece suddenly
being shattered so everyone's freaked
out in that room except there's a little
curl of a smile on the corner of his lip
because something happened that no one
could predict and it was in Jennifer's
performance because that was a real a
real moment and and in the PostScript
that's really great about this is the
Martin guitar people got notified about
it that I heard the second hand but
within a day or so and I had to think
two things one two things they said one
was do you need another one and two can
we have all the pieces for to put on
display at the Museum please because
it's such an interesting story we really
would like to you know have that
incorporated in our in the story of our
guitar history yeah so art is a surprise
art is risk and and sometimes you get a
special thing what might seem like a
negative but that's a classic Winton
moment you know that all the elements
are there but something unexpected
happens that's fascinating
capturing sound what are you using it at
some point are you loud miking people I
said you know but my how does this
working my tools are like hammers and
nails okay I use I have a broad palette
of things and I I make selections that
have to do with the tonality of the
actor where are we in context with the
character how we experiencing this
character is a more of an internal thing
what you know where are we and the
characters are in the story so I use all
the traditional tools I'll use Japanese
might call the sank and for boom work
frequently and Shep's and since and no
Mons and I use a Danish lavalier a lot
made by DPA and also Japanese thank and
lavalieres and other tools many
different mics that that doesn't cover
it but it's it's not about technique
it's about context so I try I do and I
teach on this I you need to know all of
those pieces and how to apply them but
you need to not lose sight of that the
real key tool is the filmmaker the sound
man has to be a filmmaker
just like the cameraman has to be a
filmmaker has to understand the
directors intent and the context of the
particular situation and if you think in
those terms
it creates flow on a set you're you're
responding intuitively or premeditated
either way based on what's what are we
doing what's the shot what's the scene
where does it seem to fit in against the
other scenes you know how is the whole
piece of cloth going to be affected by
the choices I make in this particular
moment and they all have to have a an
integration you know I try not to come
with an ideology because the day I come
and think I know the whole thing is the
day I should quit because I stop
learning and I'm not open to what we're
what we're really trying to get to
happen here so I don't know if that
answers your question but it's it's it's
an it's a really important piece to me
that that I don't come with a preset
notion of a pro so all of those things
are true but it all goes towards the
idea of constructing a sound a mix in a
moment that's a lot like playing an
instrument a musical instrument that
keeps us inside that character that's my
threshold when we watch it as an
audience are you believing that this is
this character and they're in this
environment having this journey if
everything that we do supports that so
if there's a noise that happens that's
unexpected my threshold is did it take
us out of the scene did it take us away
from the character if the answer's no
I'm not as emotionally disturbed by that
moment because I know that the core
thing is being protected if it does then
we're in a conversation Quinton or
whoever the director is here's that
here's an exposure here's a
vulnerability it's it's sometimes it's
just a look you know and it's not a big
conversation let's go again you know
because he does not walk away without
having that in the can period he just
doesn't he's absolutely failure cannot
cope with persistence and he is the most
persistent person I've ever seen in a
director's seat and I love that